the Batman rumors and leaks just keep on
coming let's get it out of the way from
the start
potential spoilers for the newest Batman
flick lay ahead
according to we got discovered a sources
familiar with their production are
reporting that the forthcoming film's
plot will focus on the efforts of the
world's greatest detective to track down
a serial killer on the loose in Gotham
City writer director Matt Reeves are
said to be taking his cues from the
iconic Batman comic miniseries the long
Halloween in crafting his story
previously a separate alleged leaks I
hit the web of indicated at the Robert
Pattinson starring flick will feature no
fewer than six villains with the penguin
and Catwoman being friends and center
also said to be taking part in the
villainous goings-on the Riddler
two-face Firefly and the Mad Hatter
Reeves has previously stated that he'll
be going for a much different version of
The Dark Knight than any we've seen on
film the spa 1 which will highlight the
Caped Crusader's legendary detective
skills it'll be a more grounded noir ish
take on the Batman mythos than has
previously been explored in the
characters multiple cinematic
incarnations
according to we got discovered sources a
Batman's plot will follow Bruce Wayne as
he attempts to get to the bottom of a
rash of mysterious murders plaguing
Gotham City presumably this
investigation will take him down
multiple paths and this is where the
flicks large assortment of iconic
baddies could come into play the
report's insiders assert that while
penguin Catwoman and the Riddler will be
featured prominently the remaining three
villains will be relegated to
comparatively minor roles there's no
word yet on whether or not all the bad
guys will be fully fledged villains or
if they'll be versions of those
characters who have yet to fully develop
into themed super jerks but this
wouldn't be the first time a superhero
flake would have a large assortment of
bad guys appearing in various stages of
their career just a couple years ago a
Spider Man homecoming featured the
vulture as the main villain but also
boasted appearances large and small from
Spidey bad guys like the tinkerer
scorpion the Prowler and two shockers
that's six villains right there so the
groundwork for the Batman to follow a
similar path to success has already been
laid at the movie theater overall the
Batman could be laying the foundation
for a series of movies whose antagonist
will have fleshed-out backstories and
well established motivations things
which other superhero films afflicted
with the dreaded villain bloat of
neglected to provide we're looking at
you Spider Man 3 at any rate we've
previously expressed our opinion that
Reeves are very capable filmmaker who
knows his where
around a good story knows what he's
doing and taking on the formidable task
of rebooting Batman yes again for that
matter while the internet may have gone
temporarily insane and Pattinson was
cast as Bruce Wayne there's every reason
to believe that he'll absolutely crush
it in the role Reeves as a highly
competent director of actors and he
knows just as well as anyone that
Pattinson filmography which has featured
amazing turns and smaller lesser-known
films such as 2017 s good time and 2018
s high life has revealed him to be a
much much better actor than fans only
familiar with the Twilight series would
ever expect at this point we're going to
go ahead and say that if you're not
excited for the Batman yes it's probably
a good time to rethink your position the
flick doesn't hit screens until June
25th 2021 and we'll be keeping close
tabs on every bit of information there
is to report between now and then keep
an eye on the Batphone in case it starts
to ring you never know when you might
need to pick up check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]